[Música]
actualmente el 50% de la tierra
habitable es utilizada para la
agricultura
además la industria de animales de
pastoreo es uno de los mayores emisores
de gases de efecto invernadero en la
atmósfera y agregado a esto la industria
alimentaria en general son uno de los
principales contaminantes que tenemos
para el año 2050 en tan solo 30 años la
cantidad de alimento disponible no va a
ser suficiente para alimentar a los casi
10 mil millones de personas que seremos
en ese momento realmente lo que comemos
es lo que nos está matando y está
poniendo en riesgo nuestra vida en la
tierra
pero entonces qué podemos hacer
definitivamente hay que buscar una
solución que sea masiva sostenible y
saludable la pregunta es cómo podemos
producir más alimentos de mejor calidad
nutricional utilizando menos recursos
básicamente siendo eficientes y bueno
luego de una larga búsqueda cursos e
investigación para resolver este
problema nos encontramos con una
solución
si los insectos esos bichitos de seis
patas que usualmente nos molestan tanto
y que realmente ponen un gran reto para
nuestros agricultores ahora la pregunta
es por qué insectos y de dónde viene la
idea en el año 2013 la universidad de
wageningen en holanda en conjunto con la
organización mundial de alimentación
agricultura publicaron un estudio en el
cual se mencionan todos los beneficios
que tiene la entomofagia el consumo de
los insectos para la sostenibilidad
ambiental y para los problemas de
malnutrición desde entonces se han
hablado de otras soluciones también como
algas carne de laboratorio uso de
plantas como las leguminosas sin embargo
todas coinciden en un mismo punto algo
que incluso personas líderes como
christiana figueres también menciona hay
que reducir el consumo de carne a nivel
mundial eso quiere decir que la solución
que andamos buscando debe ser accesible
a cualquier persona
realmente los insectos son una de las
especies más abundantes en el planeta y
como dato curioso el 80 por ciento de la
población mundial ya los consume de
alguna u otra manera y agregado a esto
conocemos más de 2.000 especies de
insectos comestibles ya identificados y
muchas más por identificar
principalmente aquí en nuestro país pero
eso no es todo además los insectos
pueden llegar a impactar en 8 de los 17
objetivos del desarrollo sostenible
propuestos por la organización de las
naciones unidas
para contribuir por ejemplo con los
objetivos de hambre cero y de salud de
bienestar los insectos son realmente
alimentos muy nutritivos en comparación
con la carne de res los insectos brindan
tres veces más proteínas dos veces más
grasa de la cual en su mayoría es
saludable además diez veces más cantidad
de fibra también son fuentes de
vitaminas y de minerales clave como el
zinc la vitamina b12 el calcio que son
importantes para el desarrollo y
crecimiento de las personas pero no sólo
eso sino que desde el punto de vista de
utilización de recursos eficiencia y
sostenibilidad si comparamos la
producción de animales de pastoreo en
este caso la ganadería con la producción
de grillos también para producir las
mismas cantidades ocupamos hasta dos mil
veces menos agua 25 veces menos espacio
12 veces menos alimento mientras que
producimos hasta 100 veces menos gases
de efecto invernadero en la atmósfera en
resumen son
es sumamente eficientes los insectos son
la solución más factible más sostenible
más saludable y que incluso puede llegar
a tener un impacto a nivel
socioeconómico si lo vemos de manera
racional los insectos son la solución
sin embargo sabemos que los seres
humanos no tomamos decisiones racionales
sino más bien emocionales y también
sabemos que el cambio modificar nuestros
comportamientos es el mayor reto que
hemos tenido a lo largo de nuestra
historia por eso ustedes probablemente
en este momento se están pensando wow
es increíble me encanta quiero pero
realmente quién va a estar dispuesto a
comerse un insecto es por eso que
nosotros les hacemos la pregunta a
ustedes quienes en este auditorio está
dispuesto a comerse un insecto
excelente un aplauso a todos muy bien
curiosamente esta fue la respuesta que
nos topamos desde un inicio y nos
sorprendió bastante pero nos dejó muy
optimistas ahora queremos hacerles una
serie de preguntas no tan
controversiales como a la anterior pero
igual ocupamos que levanten la mano
aquellos de los que estamos aquí nos
gusta el pan
básicamente a todos
qué tal las hamburguesas
sí
a cuántos de ustedes les gusta la carne
[Aplausos]
y bueno de esos que gritaron y que
levantaron la mano por la carne cuantos
han pensado en pegarle un mordisco a una
vaca entera
o que no esperábamos esta respuesta
muchas manos arriba sin embargo este
nuestro punto con los insectos no
estamos esperando que anden caminando
por estos pasillos busquen un insecto y
se lo meten a la boca sino más bien que
usemos esos insectos como base para
producir otros alimentos porque entonces
qué pasaría si les dijéramos que de
hecho esos alimentos y esas comidas que
a ustedes les gustan les parecen ricas
pueden ser hechos a base de insectos
bueno justamente esas reacciones y esas
caras es la mayor barrera que tienen los
insectos para decir la solución que
ocupamos sin embargo no es una barrera
que sólo tengan los insectos sino que
alimentos como el yogur los mariscos el
aguacate o incluso el sushi la han
tenido entonces nosotros no queremos
hacer de los insectos un tema de
tradiciones o de cultura sino tema de
sabor y accesibilidad económico para que
los insectos sean realmente una solución
deben cumplir los siguientes factores
deben ser consumidos a nivel mundial por
el 100% de la población pero también
accesibles económicamente a cualquier
persona en cualquier parte del mundo sin
embargo lo más importante de todo es que
tienen que saber rico
como nutricionista sé que es un tema de
salud y de seguridad alimentaria como
mercadólogo sé que es un tema de gustos
y preferencias como emprendedores
sabemos que es un tema de soluciones
integrales pero como ticos sabemos que
es un tema de sostenibilidad nuestra
presentación comenzó con datos realmente
impactantes y negativos entonces
quisiéramos ir cerrando con algunos
másteres esperanzadores y más positivos
dentro de lo cual podemos mencionar que
costa rica tiene una de las mayores
concentraciones de biodiversidad en el
mundo también tenemos un clima perfecto
durante todo el año y como ustedes
también no saben tenemos muchos insectos
y también suficiente espacio para su
reproducción la buena noticia para costa
rica es que así como somos líderes en la
producción de banano piña o incluso café
podemos llegar a convertirnos en el
productor número uno de insectos
comestibles a nivel mundial y de una
altísima calidad
costa rica ya ha sido reconocido por ser
el país verde por ser ese país que
utiliza energías limpias y renovables
costa rica es ese país que quiere ser el
primero totalmente carbono neutral somos
el país verde sostenible por excelencia
somos pura vida seamos pura vida con el
ambiente y con la alimentación hoy tengo
la oportunidad de ser un camp ha de ser
ese ejemplo real de sostenibilidad e
innovación en nosotros está hacer de los
insectos el alimento del futuro muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]